dab into that yellow baby yeah that's
gonna be your friend when you're trying
to capture this lion's mane here
how you doing lad Bible I'm Owen Wilson
here with my co-star and good friend
from father figures mr. Ed Helms we love
each other so much and today we're going
to show our appreciation for one another
by painting each other's beautiful
portraits it is relaxing you can see why
Churchill got an opinion yeah George W
yeah George W awesome even Hitler did
watercolors you did you know there were
kids in school that could draw and then
there were people that couldn't and I
couldn't I got a lot of confidence in
you and I'm not a great artist so I'm
gonna go for more of it kind of I'm
gonna try to just capture his soul
well Owens got phenomenal hair and
that's gonna just be a really tough
thing to capture there's so much texture
and I give you life in there yeah dab
into that yellow baby yeah your friend
when you're trying to capture this
lion's mane here what is brown and
sticky a stick knock knock who's there
and and who that's show business
[Music]
whoo brutal hey sometimes you got a you
got a joke to keep from crying that was
oh that's my dad's solution I'm I gotta
say I'm excited not so much to see what
Edie came up with but for Edie to see
mine because I think I wouldn't be
surprised if they put it up there you go
Big Ed Helmes that was what they called
you as a kid big yeah yeah yeah cool
it's mad man it's great I love it's like
and actually you're you're sort of
stencil s writing is it's almost Android
perfect top that well I'm not gonna try
to top it now I'm gonna make but I'm
gonna make a lateral move okay and and
show you what I've come up with which is
which is he been on Venice Beach Leon
the caricature it's not a caricature
this is an exact likeness
there's a matter of fact he's like eyes
like I've gone crazy those as soon as I
finished I thought hold on a second did
someone run in here and stick Owens
headshot on my easel because it's such a
perfect perfect rendering of your face
well guys I think you can agree that was
really special
yeah thanks for taking the time to watch
us capture the epic beauty of each other
through canvas and paint
[Applause]
[Music]